countries have constitutions and
sometimes those constitutions aren't
able to deal with certain unprecedented
events like in 1861 when some u.s states
opted to secede and make their own
america or in belgium in 1990 when the
king refused to assent to a new law and
so had to be temporarily declared
incapable of ruling in order to get
around him and pass the law anyway and
australia not wanting to be left out had
its own constitutional crisis in 1975
which saw its prime minister abruptly
fired and replaced by his opponent all
of which came alongside accusations of
cia and british royal involvement but
was this the case and how was it
resolved so first a bit of background as
of 1975 australia wasn't a 100 fully
independent nation state the british
parliament had limited authority to
legislate on behalf of australia and
queen elizabeth ii was australia's head
of state 2 and had constitutional
authority there of course she wasn't
able to personally attend all of the
country she ruled and so in her stead
sat the governor-general and the
governor-general in essence acted as the
prime minister's sort of boss and was
responsible for rubber-stamping any
legislation and calling elections anyway
from 1949 to 1972 australia had been
governed by a coalition of conservative
parties this was until they were
defeated by the labour party and its
leader goff whitlam became the prime
minister now becoming prime minister
depended on controlling australia's
house of representatives but not its
senate the balance of which sat on a
knife edge but the senate also had to
approve legislation for it to be passed
now whitlam had been elected on a
manifesto with increased spending
withdrawing from the vietnam war and
centralizing power which did not sit
well with the conservatives in the
senate whitlam also wished to
investigate the australian security
intelligence organization since it had
previously spied on his party he had
them raided in 1973 and demanded a list
of all cia operatives in australia and
soon after this he publicly accused
numerous people in positions of power of
being american spies as well and the
americans did not respond well to this
and made it clear that if whitlam
continued down this road the us would be
forced to make adjustments after this
things got much better for whitlam and
by better i mean worse because recession
whitlam called for an election in 1974
and whilst he won the house he lost the
senate meaning more deadlock and no more
spending not to worry though because
foreigners exist and whitlam had the
authority to borrow money through
australia's loan council without the
senate's approval whitlam's government
didn't tell the loans council though and
secretly tried to borrow money from
saudi arabia this was leaked and so the
politicians involved did something
clever they lied and when these lies
became public they were promptly sacked
and whitlam's reputation was damaged and
to further add insult to injury a labour
party senator resigned and was replaced
against convention by a conservative
meaning for whitlam he had zero chance
of getting anything through the senate
anymore despite this though whitlam
refused to resign or give his consent to
new elections which the government
general needed to call them and this is
where the crisis begins in earnest the
governor-general of australia at this
time was a man called john kerr a close
friend of whitlam's who was deeply
concerned about the deadlocking
government and so kur came up with a
brilliant solution he fired whitlam and
appointed the leader of the opposition
malcolm fraser as prime minister instead
the problem with this was that at the
time it wasn't exactly clear whether or
not kerr had the authority to do this
kerr had been in contact with buckingham
palace to discuss what he was and wasn't
able to do and those at the palace
reassured him that he had the authority
to dismiss the prime minister and that
if he wanted to do so he would need to
do so quickly because with a single
letter whitlam could have ker removed by
the queen the problem with this is that
in australian politics the queen is
supposed to be neutral in all affairs
and by nudging her in one direction she
would have breached that precedent which
is the issue with this entire crisis
legally everything was above board but
in terms of established precedent which
laid the foundation of trust in the
australian political system everything
was thrown out the window irrespective
of any of this whitlam was removed and
those who supported the labour party
were furious and whitlam was quick to
point out cursed historic ties with the
cia and the intelligence community in
general whereas the conservatives were
happy that the government deadlock
seemed to be coming to an end and in the
election that followed the crisis the
conservative coalition won a resounding
victory and with control of both houses
the crisis was over i hope you enjoyed
this episode and thank you for watching
with a special thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker mr
wolf sky chappelle jerry lamdin yn
hockey marvin castle jordan longley
gareth turner rod d martin bugley wiggly
captain cydog spencer lightfoot corso
wolfe gustav swan matthew shipley
winston caywood robert wetzel aaron the
white marcus asner maggie paxkowski
anthony beckett alex schwinn mo the
mukwapper coppertone spinning three
plates ben evanson charles the first
adam stalter and scottish trekkie